The world is now deeply divided by 81% of liberals and conservatives alike
Anti views towards those on the other side
But is there a fundamental biological difference between liberals and conservatives?
Floating on the surface can see some interesting differences like
Conservatives tend to eat more meat and potatoes while liberals tend to try to eat from other cultures more
In general, conservatives prefer original dogs while liberals prefer mixed breeds and liberals are fine with free hair, while conservatives prefer it to rhyme
But when we study it more, we recognize that the differences are much deeper when a magnetic resonance scan is performed
It turns out that liberals are more likely to have a larger frontal frontal cortex
Which is associated
Understanding and monitoring the conflict, while the tonsil-conservatives have a larger
Which helps to address fear and anxiety, this is logical given the years of research that have shown that people tend to be more conservative
When they feel threatened or afraid?
After Sept. 11, for example, the United States has become more politically conservative with studies showing increased support for issues
Such as national security and military spending, but studies have also found that conservatives and liberals employ different cognitive styles
Conservatives are superior when it comes to more structural problems or organizing issues
While liberals tend to be more flexible and less likely to make mistakes with issues that involve conflicting information and require fast reaction times
One study looked at the bedrooms so found that on average
Conservative student rooms were less messy than liberals
But they also suffer from pain in many different ways. So that one of the studies was able to predict who is a liberal or conservative
Just by showing them scanning the brain looking at the pictures
Containing amputation. In this case, the liberal minds were more active in the somatosensory region to the region
Which is usually activated when you are in pain, but also when you see someone else suffering
It is an essential scientific evidence of the stereotype of liberal heartfeltism
This does not mean conservatives are indifferent, but only respond to images in a different way
In America this can explain how Democrats and Republicans view the world in fundamentally different ways
It's hard to understand how someone thinks on the other side of politics because we tend to overstate the extent to which our views are believed
That some values ​​are natural, psychology refers to this bias as a false consensus. For example, if you hear Yani
In the Latina versus Laurel debate, you may feel like an ordinary person
It was crazy that anyone who could hear Laurel apply this logic to politics and you can see why people have
Polarized ideas on issues such as immigration
Rights of gun and abortion ... etc
But where do these differences emerge from? One study has shown that genetics can represent about thirty to forty percent
Of the political tendencies of the individual that may seem as much but there are still many other important factors such as the environment
And personal experiences that play enormous roles in your political views
Neuroscience is a relatively new area of ​​study with striking results and in an increasingly fragmented world
An important aspect of unity may involve the use of neuroscience to better understand the differences between them
Write a review: شوان حميد shwan_hamid @